asia's largest gallery is set to open in
hong kong this week the towering
90-meter structure has been in the works
for about a decade and features a
billion-dollar collection but the m-plus
museum is not without controversy as it
opens under a new restrictive political
climate china imposed a national
security law on hong kong in june which
critics say is an attack on the freedom
of speech and meant to crush dissent
anyone can be charged under a vague and
broad law for undermining beijing's
authority even artists
hong kong native casey wong is well
known for his outspoken political art
use of public space and even elaborate
displays at street protests
this used to be where he staged his
performances and artworks
several years ago two of his pieces were
purchased by m plus hong kong's new
contemporary art museum like this
floating house which casey wong paddled
on the harbor questioning the city's
expensive tiny flats
my artwork was critical of the injustice
of society
i felt that m plus was professional in
picking the collections they were
interested in those reflecting local
stories and histories
m-plus is a highlight of hong kong's
newly built cultural district a
government-funded landmark project that
has taken over two decades to realize
with its collection of over 8 400
artworks the museum positions itself as
a top regional art hub and aims to rival
western heavyweights such as london's
tate modern and new york's museum of
modern art
what draws particular attention is its
arguably largest and finest collection
of contemporary chinese art in the world
thanks to swiss collector uli sig who
donated and sold over 1 500 pieces to m
plus including some created by chinese
distant artist ai weiwei
a famous picture of him raising the
middle finger at beijing's tiananmen
square in the 1990s was censored on m
plus museum website that's after
pro-beijing politicians and media
contended it could spread hatred against
china
but pictures from the same series in
front of the white house and the swiss
parliament remain
authorities have confirmed that the
censored picture won't be shown at the
opening exhibition
and vowed to work with the national
security unit if any artwork violates
the beijing-imposed security law
it seems to me it's a series of
systematic attacks against the art and
cultural sector
the political crackdown from beijing is
becoming more tangible
the museum authorities have let us down
by giving up its autonomy and betraying
the artistic profession
why should an artwork be judged by the
police
the much anticipated museum kicks off a
new era for hong kong's cultural sphere
at a time when its future is clouded by
beijing's tightening grip on freedom of
speech
casey wong won't have the chance to
witness his artwork being displayed in m
plus that's because he left hong kong
for taiwan over the summer
a new platform doesn't necessarily
facilitate art development if it helps
exploit freedom of art expression
self-censorship is getting more common
among artists who tend to make their
works more abstract but i believe that
the greater the limitation
the greater the creativity that will
evolve
let's say goodbye
with a smile dear
and so he said goodbye to hong kong
his last performance was a farewell
music video dedicated to the city
filmed before his departure to taiwan
in it he sings vera lynn's will meet
again
asking hong kong to keep smiling till
the blue skies drive the dark clouds
away
[Music]
we're now joined by dw correspondent
phoebe kong phoebe long delays it's over
budget but the m-plus museum is finally
open what are some of the highlights
well emplous is a star project of hong
kong's west kowloon cultural district
it was a newly built
landmark like pretty much located at the
heart of hong kong in downtown
of the city so today we are also invited
to the media preview like um having a
fresh look at the new galleries that are
there those artworks that contains like
many of the paintings drawings and most
of them were created by artists from
mainland china
hong kong of course across asia and uh
some of the pieces were also created by
um western artists but um those not the
majorities of the art pieces so it
features very much like put the focus on
the asian contemporary art especially
the mainland chinese artwork in recent
decades um so we also found some like
artwork like um echoing some of the
chinese political and social incidents
in recent decades
now we saw in the report that part of an
iway way series was removed from the
museum website and won't be part of the
exhibit can you talk to us about what
happened there
so earlier this year in hong kong
some of the probation lawmakers and also
state-owned media outlets criticized
some of the art collections of the
empress museum of insulting
the china and also like inciting hatred
against the chinese government and also
china um so they uh criticized that
those artwork may violate the national
security imposed by beijing in hong kong
last june so um after that like it
triggered a huge controversy among the
artistic sphere and also like among
society it triggered huge debate on like
how to deal with the new artwork under
the national security law so after that
um like um one of the uh
pieces that i put on the spotlight is ai
wayways famous photograph showing his
middle finger to beijing's tenement
square
so um that photo was particularly
removed from empress museum official
website without specific reasoning so
today at the media preview the head of
the cultural district reiterated again
that
those artwork including highways photos
are now under review that
is not yet known that whether it will be
displayed in the future but
surely today in the preview and at the
opening exhibition those photographs are
absent from the galleries right now
phoebe hong kong has been burgeoning as
a hub for arts and culture in the region
how much does china's national security
law undermine and hurt that label
well the sweeping national security law
has been imposed in hong kong since last
last june it has been almost one and a
half year and here it has created um a
very huge impact among like almost all
kinds of sectors in hong kong so it's
not only affecting the artists we have
heard many like um voices from the
artistic sectors that they will be like
self-censoring their works because of
the pressure and also the pressure from
the commercial sectors and the financial
pressure they're facing so um they're
pretty like pessimistic to the future of
the like art and culture development in
hong kong
dw correspondent phoebe kong reporting
for us thank you phoebe